>> Tucker: WE'LL CLOSE THE ONLY
WAY WE KNOW HOW ON FRIDAY, DAN
BONN GINO NEWS EXPLOSION.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, DAN.
>> I'M EXCITED.
I HAVE THREE DOOZIES.
LET'S START WITH EXPLOSIVE STORY
NUMBER TWO.
I WATCHED YOUR DE BLASSO
INTERVIEW, WELL DONE, GIVE THE
GUY CREDIT, WHO CAME ON THE
SHOW.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
>> THE GUY US HOVERING ABOUT 2%
ABOVE THE GRIM REAPER IN
APPROVAL POLLS.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, MAN, TUCKER,
CAN THIS DUDE DUCK A QUESTION OR
WHAT?
I MEAN IT WAS LIKE, HE WAS LIKE
TYSON COMING IN.
HE CAN'T -- I THINK WE HAVE SOME
VIDEO OF THIS GUY DUCKING JUST
ABOUT EVERY QUESTION.
CHECK THIS OUT.
>> Tucker: THE CITY IS DIRTY AND
GETTING DIRTIER.
ONE OF MY PRODUCERS TOLD ME
YESTERDAY HE WAS IN A CROWDED
SUBWAY CAR AND A MARN DROPPED
HIS TROUSERS AND DEFECATED IN
THE CAR AND NOBODY DID ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
YOU ENDORSED DECRIMINALIZING
PUBLIC URINATION.
>> THAT'S FALSE.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT FALSE, I WAS
LIVING THERE WHEN YOU DID IT.
>> Tucker: ANY OFFENSE LIKE
THAT, THERE'S A SUMMONS, THERE'S
A PENALTY, DEFINITELY A
SANCTION.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT IN THAT.
>> Tucker: YOU WEAKENED THE
SANCTION AGAINST PUBLICURECATION
AND THE CITY SMELLS LIKE URINE.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I GO ALL OVER NEW YORK CITY ALL
THE TIME.
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR DECADES AND
DECADES.
THIS CITY IS MORE ORDERLY, AND
CLEANER AND SAFER THAN IT'S BEEN
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
>> AND THE WORST PART, TUCKER,
IS WHEN HE DID ANSWER THE
QUESTION HE MADE IT UP.
YOU WERE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, THEY
CHANGED THE PUBLIC URINATION
FROM A CRIMINAL SUMMONS TO A
CIVIL.
HE COULDN'T EVEN TELL THE
DIFFERENCE.
>> Tucker: IT'S A CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE, PUBLIC URINATION.
WILL HAVE WILL HAVE WHAT A B.S.
ARTIST.
>> DOES GUY LIVE IN NEW YORK ANY
MORE?
I MEAN.
OKAY, I HAE TWO MORE.
SMOESIVE STORY NUMBER TWO, THE
DIVIDE IN CHRONICLES CONTINUE.
THE BIDEN CHRONICLES, THE
STORIES ARE GREAT.
THEY REALLY ARE.
BIDEN TELLS STORIES ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, THEY'RE
TOUCHING, LART BREAKING.
THE PROBLEM, TUCKER, NONE OF
THEM HAPPENED.
THEY'RE NOT REAL STORIES.
I MEAN, LISTEN, I GET IT, I
HAERMD YOU SAY, THERE'S A PART
OF ME THAT FEELS BAD.
I THINK BARACK OBAMA GAVE HIM
GOOD ADVICE.
SNOW JOE, YOU DON'T NEED.
THIS THE CHRON I CANLES ARE
WONDERFUL STORE REQUIRES.
THE PROBLEM, JOE, THEY DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
NICE WORK AND ALL BUT MAYBE IT'S
TIME TO THINK THIS THING
THROUGH.
NOT WORK IT OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
GO AHEAD.
>> Tucker: I JUST -- MY HEART IS
BROKEN.
I FEEL SAD ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
I THINK YOU COULD HAVE RETIRED,
BE IN BARBADOS WITH THE
GRANDKIDS.
>> I HEARD YOU SAY THAT LAST
NIGHT.
YOU'RE RIGHT, IT IS IT'S TOUGH
TO WATCH THE I LIKED THE GUY AND
IT'S NOT ENDING WELL.
POOR JOE.
STORY NUMBER ONE IS MY FAVORITE.
THE HYPOCRITICAL DEMOCRATS
DURING THAT CNN SEVEN-HOUR
COMMERCIAL FOR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, YOU HEARD THE CLIMATE
CHANGE, WHATEVER IT WAS, THEY
WANT TO BAN EVERYTHING.
THESE ARE THE WORST KIND OF
HYPOCRITES.
HERE'S WHAT THEY WANT TO BAN.
VOTE DEMOCRATS IN 2020, YOU WANT
TO BAN COAL, NATURAL GAS, AIR
TRAVEL, THE COMBUSTION ENGINE,
TRACKING, OFFSHORE DRILLING,
MEAT, CHEESE BURGERS, I'M NOT
GOING ANYWHERE WITHOUT MY
CHEESEBURGER.
EVEN WORSE THEY WANT TO BAN
PLASTIC STRAWS.
FOR THE CARDBOARD ONES.
I GOT A LITTLE KOMBUCHA HERE.
>> Tucker: DAN BONGINO.